great to be here I went here
undergraduate it's not like something
magic about coming back to your
undergrad institution which is fun 75 to
79 embarrassing they say cool
and so we have a big team at Penn and
across the country in the world of
political scientists like Phil tetlock
psychologists like barb Miller's data
scientists like me and lots of other
people on my PhD student Vela we'll talk
about the tool we'll do this stuff at
the end trying to understand everything
we can about how to make better
forecasts not so much quantitative
statistical things but predictions how
happy will I be this person that I hire
will this product launch work and in our
case mostly geopolitical forecasts what
will happen in China or Russia or Africa
I'm gonna try and do that there's a
question well we can't we can't do
better than three things today
I'm trying cover them all first of all I
want to make a big plea of why you
should actually forecast and track
outcomes make falsifiable forecasts
that's my biggest message it's really
simple and really stupid and widely
ignored across both the commercial and
the industrial world secondly I want to
talk about we've learned about how to
select train and organize forecasters we
put together thousands of people making
hundreds of forecasts you have millions
of forecasts collected we've done a lot
of experiments I'm going to try and
summarize them in this case in about 15
minutes
and then I'm gonna sneak in a little
tiny bit of statistics just for fun but
it won't be too much statistics or sort
of the algorithmic side of putting these
together just I can't resist because I'm
a computer scientist by training only
recently a psychologist a couple this is
all funded by the IRS CIA so yeah we've
done things so research shows that
people often make bad predictions
psychology is full of people forgetting
that predictions regress to the mean
people are really bad at taking lots of
information and combining it computers
are much better often into
feelings you interview someone you
really understand they're great how good
they are but that's an illusion mostly
modern interviews are structured how
well do you do that but you can do
better now it is the case that you're
always to be uncertain knowing what was
gonna happen Putin knowing this for the
Arab Spring there are lots of things
you're gonna get wrong but we've gotten
better at doing it so I'm not gonna
promise do it well all I want to say is
if you look at enough people and think
about it you can learn to do a better
job I'm gonna try and be a little more
precise about what that means so
historically particularly in the
intelligence agencies it from this but
in most companies in general in life
forecasts are often of the form there's
a reasonable chance that a good chance
that Hillary will win that's nice but
that's not the sort of forecast I want
what happens is when people say words
like real possibility or distinct
possibility when you go back and ask
them on a scale of zero chance 200% what
did you mean you get a frightening ly
wide range of what is possibility or
impossibility or sure thing mean these
are actually real data if you look at
this sort of in a more general thing
across fields what's the probability
election outcome if you're journalist
you know it's too close to call
if you're a weather forecast probably of
rain 50% in Philadelphia is kind of snow
hey might snow next week snow investor
the probability of destroying the
economy zero risk high risk no one could
have foreseen right there's a lot of
reasons to shade your predictions in
terms of where they're gonna go and to
not give actual numbers that could be
falsified in particular pundits people
are professional at going on television
and talk about these things are really
good at using words like could and might
and possibly there's a risk that
recovery in the eurozone could install
and a man might weaken so that deflation
would be a real possibility
what does this tell you nothing nothing
nothing nothing okay but it's a nice
equilibrium the pundits don't have to
admit that their errors and the
policymakers aren't constrained by nasty
facts this is very comfy we and to the
credit the intelligence agencies are
saying can we change that can we
actually change the culture and actually
make falsifiable predictions so I
probably don't need to remind people
that lots of bad decisions happen and
these are quotes from major US
policymakers there's a serious
possibility a chance of success of the
Bay of Pigs first what is a fair chance
mean yeah a little unclear easy to evade
pieces their statements of mass
destruction I don't say that the
government should have known whether
Iraq had or didn't have weapons of mass
destruction but we judged that Iraq has
continuous what excuse me
probably one is that really what you
believe I'm very skeptical about
probability ones yes they do be the
judge and what's the chance they're
being wrong zero they judge it has it
that's a nice weasel word but again it's
not my kind of a forecast yes you can be
vague you can't learn and one of things
I'm most interested is in people getting
better how can we train our analysts
ourselves to be better to do that you
need to make quantitative predictions
not vague qualitative ones and get
feedback were you right or wrong which
means actually writing it down learn you
need to keep score and that's really
what we did and I think probably in
Silicon Valley don't need to argue this
there's a culture I worked at Google
places that least for serving ads it
really does keep score
but measurement is important you want to
change things you want to learn you want
progress you need to measure it so how
do we measure it I'm gonna yes
last year so how many decades was just
fumbling around without measuring things
like this up is actually very good at
measuring small things does putting a
little gold box help over silver box
they're awesomely good they do thousands
of randomized trials but the hard part
is keeping score and measuring things
that are much bigger and much general
the product launch the move toward X Box
the phone so the tiny things Microsoft
has always been from my memory extremely
good but the big things that matter
that's a feeling and again it's hard to
know so I'm going to show a bunch of
measurements of score which is the
breyer score the details aren't
important
but I'm going to ask people for
probabilities a number between zero and
one and we're gonna score how close it
is the correct if you say yes if you say
90% and it's yes then you're going to
get an error of 1 minus the point 9 you
said it would happen and zero minus the
point when you said it wouldn't happen
squared when it happened zeros didn't
happen
you're gonna err 0.02 did really well
and if you say 50/50 you'll get a 50%
the details don't matter it's a squared
error loss yeah those of us who've gone
to college and calculus so in the case
of that you for instance your date for
forecast when a day progresses and the
date for forecast because of day three
forecasts are you consuming a
recomputation every day what's the
probability of the current ruler of
Ghana being in power on January 1st of
next year and we take a profit every day
doesn't change every day but think takes
wherever they want and at the end of the
time we then sum up their score if they
were perfectly correct every time
they've got a zero if they were dead
wrong every time actually they have a
two so this is a scoring that says that
if you were omniscient you get zero
error if you flip coins randomly every
time you get a point five and if you're
just customly if you're if you're so
clever to be wrong every time you get it
too but we ask them every day how is
this doing what's gonna happen what's
gonna have us gonna happen squirt
then the details don't matter
technically any proper scoring rule will
do but this is a good one widely used so
what do we do we ran for successive
years of tournaments funded by IEEE ARPA
this is the funding agency of the
intelligence agencies who are interested
in predicting geopolitical events by our
mandate we're looking only at non-us
questions and questions were always
formed of something as examples which
countries will officially announce they
will join the Asian infrastructure
investment bank and they were formed
mostly in dichotomous wielders companies
don't the country enjoy it or not
sometimes in multi outcomes I've asked
wind will Nikolas vacate the office
their president has way a little bit in
fact the question was by X date what's
the probability he will have vacated
again very precise questions it turns
out unbelievably hard to ask quite
precise questions we had political
scientists working like lawyers here
trying to formulate exactly not will
they be reelected but will they be in
power which is not the same in much of
the world what does it mean to be in
power
what definition of that what does it
mean to solve well to say will they
launch a ground offensive again that's
slightly vague what do I mean by a
ground offensive so very precisely
defined questions when my collaborators
Phil tetlock likes to call clairvoyant
questions one that you could actually if
you knew it would have a clear answer
yes or no that's I think a big piece and
really hard cool so here's typical
tracking across the time as years this
is running from December 2011 into China
2012 and we have predictions will Putin
Putin the reunion will be inaugurated as
president of Russia in 2012 question and
we can see tracking across here a bunch
of different groups and I'll talk later
about we try doing teams individuals we
try different training of different
kinds what helps what people are good at
it what people are bad
no there's predictions every day some of
the group's the prediction market here
is going fairly downs it's probably not
happening
three-team median is doing better and
all combinations of teams is doing quite
well too right
on average the wisdom of crowds is
helping nothing and the question is wind
prediction markets sounds pretty cool
other ways to do it what works how to
train them no so what we did amazingly
at the beginning of each year everybody
got somewhere between one hour and at
most two hours of online training the
forecasters are all over the world this
is an online training course now one
question asked is will an hour of
training change people's accuracy a year
later it's well known that a year of
statistics doesn't include improve
people's probability estimates
particularly well they still think
ninety second principles are fifty will
working in teams helped or hurt
groupthink or sharing of information
where these teams in the field of people
good point so people are always to
bachelor's degree somewhere political
scientist somewhere students and analyst
schools a lot work computer scientists
somewhere hedge fund managers all over
the map and we have a crapload of
information about them which I'll talk
about later yeah they know they know the
award for each treatment each group
there's a list of names of the lowest
Breyer score of the best people that was
it no monetary prize we paid them a
token like fifty bucks a year which is
way under minimum wage for what it takes
to actually run these things but you
know people are into it and all you got
out at the end was your name on a list
of how well you did good questions okay
so we beat taking a random set of people
and averaging them by 50 to 70 percent
on the breyer score Darrow
we've got a big improvement we were
enough better than the other teams that
I are but cancelled most other teams and
give us a bunch of the money and took
them on as collaborators it was really
nice
loomed away and I think we learned four
things get the right key bolt which I'll
talk about and we took the top couple
percent and call them super forecasters
and we did them exploit good
interactions put them on teams in the
right way either on teams or prediction
markets and I'll talk about the relative
benefits of those two today teach them
amazingly actually an hour of online
teaching changed forecasts throughout
which I find staggering I was the other
side of that bet but I learn something I
was wrong
that's good and develop good algorithms
to integrate and combine these forecasts
it turns out that averaging probability
estimates is really stupid and even
averaging real numbers is mostly stupid
too for reasons I'll get to cool so
first question is are there really great
people this is not a earthquake hello
the East Coast I was think this is what
California looks like this nice McGrath
but these are the questions closing from
the twenty-six hundred ninety-ninth we
took the best hundred people and looked
at their average score and the worst
hundred people remember higher is worse
higher scores and on average the worst
hundred of the first 25 questions are
pretty reliably worse in the future
people who are bad in the past are bad
in the future okay that's encouraging
there's some signal there they get some
rights I'm wrong but it helps so we want
people who are good who we want fluid
intelligence Ravens test IQ helps
political knowledge less so actually
somewhat surprisingly perhaps the
computer scientists were just as good at
forecasting as the political scientists
being experts on things didn't help now
maybe it's because our ranger problems
was huge it was everywhere in the world
except the US that include economics and
politics and military civil unrest lots
of things maybe nobody knows all those
things but for whatever reason it turned
out that having a professorship of
political science at a good school was
not vastly helpful
quite a few publications have found the
opposite many people are much better in
their domain area when questions what's
your domain area are you as
knowledgeable about what's happening in
Ghana as you aren't happening with the
economics of the EC are you as good at
forecasting oil prices as you are about
so nobody in our area knew all the stuff
if you're gonna do well you had to go
out there and go to the web find things
read stuff figure it out and I think
it's not contradicting the idea of
subject matter experts but it's noting
that if there's a broad enough set of
questions
maybe that particular expertise doesn't
help yeah an IQ test there are two
things there's fluid intelligence which
is sheer horsepower how smart you are
and crystallized intelligence how much
do you know so these are psychology
terms so fluid intelligence measured by
the Ravens test in this case is those
little diagrams with the circles and
this little lines in them that just
check pure IQ as opposed to knowledge
well peace like you more actively open
minded cognitive styles people who
fought more thought longer were more
flexible in their thinking and we have
again questions for measuring these
creating for cognition people wanted to
complete figure it out
don't take the final first answer is the
final answer people who measure things
in tents or Plato five in probability
when people said Oh point two five point
five point seven five we can see how
accurate someone was if they're saying
25% 50% as opposed to 30% the 30% 35%
33% guy or women better I'll talk about
Fermi izing breaking problems into lots
of little pieces decompose it I'll talk
more about that later how to do that
people have believed that you actually
the world was deterministic you could
understand it you could figure it out
they don't believe in fate they believe
you can figure things out and belief
that you actually can learn stuff it's
sort of funny self-fulfilling cycle
right I got I like Carol Dweck stuff
here Stanford growth mindsets
it meet Carol she's good okay find good
people smart ones who want to think
about things and figure them out teens
versus not he's we tried prediction
markets here's one of a classic you know
how much do that on this last year's
Obama okay and remember him or more
modernly
here's today's version of the Democrat
winner-take-all vs. Republicans
prediction markets you get a buck if the
Democrats we in the popular election why
I care but that I don't know versus what
is much less done is prediction polls
and I don't mean opinion polls not who
will you vote for but who do you think
will win if you go and take a random set
of people of our piece and say who will
you vote for that's not very helpful
it's a very biased sample and have a lot
of Trump supporters out there you ask
who do you think will win you learn
something much better
make sense and we'll talk a little bit
more about when you might want to do
each of these but they're both different
ways of getting wisdom of crowd lots of
opinions the other question was should
people be put on teams or not and most
alas said no teams leave the group think
you get too much reinforcement of stuff
here's what we found here's the
prediction market earnings how much
money they made more dollars is good
individuals teams and the super teams of
the best two percent here's briar score
smaller is better
this is accuracy squared error loss
independent predictors teams super teams
ting are a lot better than individuals
now we know that teens often lead to
boot think what's different here first
of all our teams are not sitting around
a smoke-filled room with a guy with a
tie or someone's for long hair our teams
are all internet this is all distributed
there is no obvious social hierarchy
it's got a very different structure than
many of the old-fashioned team studies
and I think there's some evidence
though they are they have basically a
structured platform for sharing
information what we have is a way for
them to text each other put comments on
theirs
we tell them you're on a team you guys
are individual I'll just rank your names
you're on a team you'll each make your
own predictions but thus leaderboard
will have your team name will never show
where your name shows up your goal is to
make your team have the most accurate
predictions if you two disagree you may
each put your conflicting probabilities
in it's okay with me will average them
but the team at the end is what matters
and the team say hey here's what I think
no no that will never work I know that
you're the EC they're way slower than
that that's ridiculous so the average
the probability other ones from the team
in the end is this is the average of the
scores of the people on the team right
everybody gets their bar scores actually
I was the prior scores we average your
school they're your team scores the
average the people on it if you can get
his score up I say no no you're crazy
that's not really what's happening in
Russia they're just saying that but
that's cheap talk or not you could
convince him you can raise the team
score okay so the incentive based only
on leaderboard to convince the other
people on your team and they share each
other's predictions and the reasons
behind it and we have all this
communication it's all electronic cause
you can analyze it that's another talk
make sense so these sort of teams have
to be wonderfully good much better and
there's this super additive effect that
once you put together smart people who
are engaged on the same team then they
just boom they get really excited to get
really engaged they really do well much
better than they did even and these
often both year ones even they did
before as individuals these are
prediction markets there's no real money
here
I guess no this is all fake money this
is all fake money on a prediction
markets everybody gets their fifty bucks
a year and you've got a list on the
prediction market or how much money you
made no real money you can argue that
real markets are going to be efficient
and better that's an interesting
question but I'm interested in many
cases where you're inside the
intelligence AZ or side your company you
don't want to run a real money market
what you want to do is aggregate the
opinions of your experts into an overall
piece there most companies don't want to
run prediction markets with real money
internally lots of them from Ford to
Google have run fake money prediction
markets but it's not really common
through in real money ones every
probability is a bet no the prediction
market condition they actually put
dollars how much will you pay for the
firth for this outcome in the prediction
poll they're just giving a number
between zero and one each person so
they're quite different we also asked
them how confident you are but that's
they're not rewarded on that that's just
another piece of information for us to
take for our algorithms they all argue
and the end each of them has their chunk
of funny money each person puts whatever
he or she thinks they believe you can
fight against each other on that make
sense yep because you said you had a
bunch of people John and I are and I'm
convinced he's wrong can I help my team
by over
and I know which way he's going to be
wrong if they sneak but can I hope help
my team score by instead I think it's
really 80 but I think he's gonna go 60
in the prediction market you can the
prediction poll you can't interesting
thing is that some people like the
prediction market that's fun and
gamified more people dislike it because
at least among our people who are
participants into this were into
politics I don't want to think about
gaming the system all I want to do is
understand what's happening in the Congo
and give my probability and talk to my
people so we had more people who
disliked the prediction market and don't
like having to think about what these
are applications are correctly correctly
so and so yeah so it does turn out that
people were better in the diction archit
are better predictors but not as
reliably as pure polls so one thing I
argue is that this gamification has
maybe gone out of control in some of
these prediction market settings at
least for these sort of cases with
intrinsic interest just let people make
the predictions do the leaderboards see
how they do cool training amazingly
training worked if you want you can go
into training good judgment calm and
take the training where we've done these
I'm gonna walk really quickly through an
hour-long training in about four minutes
first thing is really obvious after you
think about it some things are more
predictable and you can figure out some
things are less convertible just purely
random noise you want to think about the
things that are sort of in the middle
where it's either blazingly obvious what
the answer is nor impossibly hard don't
waste your time if you're not having a
chance of figuring something out I did
not yeah oh yeah that one I know yep
okay that one's fine it's still yeah a
little left that one I do know that the
piece there yeah I would MIT biggest one
in terms of methodology reference class
ask a question will this dictator who
has been in power for twenty years
remain in power for one year it's nice
to sound bayesian compared to comparable
people
what's comparable what's the right thing
is it all African dictators dictators
have been in power for five years
somewhere outside of after not ten years
twenty years maybe the health matters
what's the right group to compare
against and that actually takes a lot of
thinking and I'm an AI guy I like all
these companies deep networks outside
really hard to automate this sort of
forecasting of finding what the right
reference class is to compare against
the right balancing inside and outside
view you ask most people will these
couple be married in five years nice
trying to a precise thing rather than
happy most people look at that sort of
thing think now how happy they feel and
translate that to a probability that's a
really bad way to go with making
forecasts much better is to start with
some statistics we know how what
fraction of first marriage is second
marriages third marriages and in divorce
after a certain amount of time start
with the base rate for the right
comparison class then adjust it based on
what you know about the person hugely
useful piece and something can teach
someone and after year if they practice
it every week with real feedback the
training work I think because they're
getting feedback they're using it every
time you figure out did I do the right
thing or not just adjusted your
condition he said yes I was right all
along
you just needed a bit more information
so the truth so he said the trainee
class didn't work but it worked because
you did this other thing instead so you
you fixed your initial predictions you
could change the world yep so you never
run then I change it learned try and be
as fine-grained and precise as you can
try not to say maybe or unlikely but try
and give an actual numb
yeah I'm missing all sorts of things
there break things up into pieces
classic thing from physicists fear me
how many piano tuners are there in
Chicago how many people how many
households how many pianos how long does
it take figure out the number say Boston
Consulting Group this was a classic sort
of game you would play in the interview
circuit break things up into pieces you
could answer lots of specific pieces
about it and multiply them back up again
so decomposing problems and finally
post-mortems this is what happened why
did I get it right why did I get it
wrong try to learn from it and these are
particularly useful and helpful on the
team where you get the team's coming
together and saying crap we should have
got that or we got it right to get lucky
or was it because we were skillful again
this learning and self feedback piece
this is my one really messy slide but
yeah i'll show you a formal mediation
model to show how much these things
little numbers on them so briar score
down here the answer smaller is better
actively open minded thinking slightly
lowers the people buyer score training
bigger effect teams bigger effect and
teams also effects positively time spent
viewing questions so teams both directly
make you better and they make you spend
more time looking at stuff which makes
you better if you work harder at it you
get better results
intelligence yep these are correlation
coefficients cameras all correlation
coefficients sorry thank you political
knowledge help some so here's a minus
1.6 lowering thing political knowledge
also have more political knowledge also
update their bleeds more often they are
more engaged they do a better job which
makes a big effect
Ravens IQ we did numerous cognitive
reflection tasks a bunch of different
components of IQ I don't want to go
through details except to note that
there's a sort of key pieces of
mediation being smart working on teams
political knowledge both make you more
involved
they were often spend more time and even
above and beyond that make you better
that's a lot of slides there but that's
it
cool forth driver and final one extreme
izing algorithms it turns out that
averaging probabilities is a really
crappy thing to do first of all they're
not Gaussian and I'm not a little bit
more but how to combine pieces there but
we do surveys of individuals the teams
are better the supers are better if we
do the right statistical hocus-pocus
which I'll talk about a second the
individuals who are really crappy the
wisdom of the crowd comes out they do a
lot better almost as good as the supers
we get sort of somewhat similar effects
in prediction markets but extreme izing
there isn't help as much so what am I
saying is that if you have a bunch of
crappy forecasters if you combine them
in the right way which is not averaging
them you can do almost as well as having
the top 2% working in really good teams
not quite but close
exactly so a team a group that has no
communication helps don't get me wrong
it's reliably across all four years we
get better per the teams but you can do
something that's somewhat close to it by
actually doing a good combination and it
turns out somewhat surprisingly or not
I'm not sure averaging is a horrible
thing to do not only for probabilities
but also for real valued forecasts and I
was taught sort of all of Statistics is
averaging stuff but we'll come to the
sort of technical part of the talk and
show that that's not the case and give
some intuition same numbers we control
all these are controlled for a number of
people yeah absolutely so all the supers
are selected out as better people
everything else is random assignments
equal numbers of people control over
everything we could
so what happens these are part of the
labels all in a second this is looking
at how much better or worse in this case
higher is worse different groups do
compared to the prediction market if you
just take an average of individuals or
average of people on teams you're 20 to
40% worse than picture market prediction
markets are really good compared to just
averaging people they seem to have a
certain magic there well first thing I
do is not average everybody's forecast
about the whole thing but decay throw
out more of the older forecasts and now
the bridge of markets are still
frictional I could use a clothes every
day
we're value at the end of the day what's
your prediction it's still the case that
it's ten to twenty ten percent for teams
playing percent worse to average
probabilities of a group than do a
picture market a picture market is still
good compared to average now we can
weight people based on how certain they
are and their history of performance and
now we're pretty much matching we can't
distinguish ourselves from the richer
markets if we do clever transformations
of the team's average by moving the more
extreme if the team says 0.7 which is a
point eight if they say 0.85 we say
point 9 extreme line using the
probabilities at that point we're
statistically seemingly beating the
prediction markets you can't liar so you
can take the median yeah
it turns out that just taking the median
which throws a dollar is much better
than mean but still not nearly as good
as an intelligent combination
interesting contradiction here
individuals tend to be too overconfident
however averaging a bunch of people
gives a company even if they're all each
in the
confident gives a combination that is
under confident okay I was right
explained that apparent paradox to you
that's my my last 20 minutes yep a
little bit counter to then extreme
editing all that now granular is how
precise it's a measure including of how
hard you think it's I think entirely
separate from this notion that says that
even though individuals are often
overconfident although our super
forecasters are remarkably well
calibrated normal people and often
things are often overconfident
it's still the case that when you
average people that you wanted to take
into account some information overlap
I'm going to come to that last perhaps a
non obvious piece right it sounds like
you extreme izing is still healthy no
this is not the extreme not for an
individual not extreme izing your score
I take 30 individuals if I average them
and then extreme eyes I do better so the
individuals are set picture 30
individuals combined together versus 30
people on a team but still combining
through the individual forecasts which
is not the same degree of overconfidence
miss calibration of to the individuals
you might think you take a bunch of
overconfident people an average them you
would get something that's overconfident
converse you're using one metric
individually and then the inverse metric
for the yeah so in general for
individuals you want to take their
forecasts and shrink them a little bit
back toward the mean so if you have
individuals who are here you want to you
out here you want to pull them in if you
have average of individuals you want to
pull them away from it make them bigger
it's sort of backwards so let me try and
talk about that in my last third about
the idea of information diversity now
there's a large literature that argues
that more diverse teams are better
we tried slicing and dicing our people
in a million ways male and female
political scientists and computer
scientists no benefit
that sort of diversity didn't help us
now argh there people are not diverse
enough but there were men and women
young and old PhDs and bachelors none of
that sort of diversity help them have
any difference in our statistics our
people all look sort of the same okay
maybe that's the volunteers we have I'm
not saying it's too so that's it they're
all people who are geeks interested in
political science forecasting but we did
find that their correlation structures
over people people tend to
systematically agree or disagree with
people and that's something we can use
to do a better job have people make a
whole bunch of forecasts and
interestingly even if I don't know the
truth each of you makes a bunch of
forecasts
you guys always agree you tend to
disagree more when I combine them I want
to down wait the two guys who are always
agreeing don't count them twice they're
probably both reading the New York Times
that's great but I was with the New York
Times once you're saying something
different could because you're stupid
could because you're smart I don't know
but it's a good thing to do
statistically my experience are going to
give you a little bit more weight and
that is this notion of information
diversity if you think you know there's
a 5% chance of this guy dying of a heart
attack next year and you know as a 5%
chance of a cou the things do is not
average two to five percents the chance
of him being out of power roughly 5%
plus 5% or maybe
minus the product to those which is
basically zero it's closer to 10% you
with me so this notion that if people
have different information it should
push things more extreme is the key this
information diversity we tried to see if
we could track what people were reading
and we ask them questions are they
boom stirs or doom stirs or left or
right he never could find a systemic
fill believes and realpolitik versus
yeah we could never find a good question
to measure this conceptual diversity but
we had a lot of answers I'm a
statistician I can just measure the
reverse T together I wanna argue is that
the statistics that I was taught when I
was an undergrad at Stanford and
still decent pen says the way you
estimate things is there's truth that
plus noise you make a bunch of
measurements you average them and the
average out the noise and that's great
yes that's right and this is the
interesting thing which says that if
you're measuring something repeatedly
with noise averaging is the right thing
to do but that's not Gaussian linear but
that's not the model icing in the world
isit and their people each of whom read
different newspapers some read Russians
some don't some put more credence in a
realpolitik other ones actually believe
what politicians say more each expert
sees overlapping chunks of information
they read some of the same everyone our
group we into New York Times but they're
posted they read different things too
they have different things they take at
it and they use that information to make
forecast I can see who's correlating
with who and use that to reweighed it
it's a little more work mathematically
but it works quite better here's the
math slide which for those very math
geeks the rest cannot worry too much I
get a set of estimates from my
forecasters I'm going to find the
covariance between them how much they
tend to agree or disagree I feel picture
in a second what that looks like and
then well for real valued estimates if
you assume some simple Gaussian model
unbiased you're gonna estimate that
looks roughly like the inverse
covariance matrix times observations
with a little other pieces there one of
these covariance matrices look like here
are our five most active forecasters and
you can see that some of them are highly
correlated these super forecasters a and
B are really close to each other but not
as highly colored with super cluster C
these individual a and be much less
forecasting so you can see actually
which people tend to agree with each
other darker color which one tend to
disagree more with me that is the
covariance matrix here's our covariance
paste Christ 100 forecasters a larger
set and you can see again their sets of
them that tend to agree a lot in
particularly super forecasters working
on teams share information do things
they tend to agree a lot the teams in
red agree somewhat less
the people working in isolation
individually tend to agree even less so
the correlation not surprising if I'm on
a team with you we tend to make more
highly correlated forecasts oh and we
should down wait each of ourselves a
little so as not to double count we're
not perfectly correlated yeah you're you
diagonal they're also showing the
variance which shows your super
forecaster a chance to make more extreme
predictions is that a correct
interpretation yeah so the model had
sort of two pieces which makes it one is
the covariance the other is some
estimate of what fraction the total
information someone sees so we have
overlapping chunks of information and
people vary in whether they see a tiny
bit of information or a lot of it and
the super forecasters are closer to
seeing more of the information and if
you have more information
that's all assume people are rational
with some sort of gas you know if you
have more information you should be
taking more extreme if you're ignorant
you should say 0.5 the more you know the
closer you get to 0 or 1 averaging the
0.5 and 2025 means a couple different
things play fine either means I'm really
knowledgeable and it's 5050 or it means
I'm clueless averaging the point 5
clueless guy and the point and I I'm
pretty sure guy bad idea the point 95
guy just saw him clueless right
uninformed and that's again why you
don't want to move it if you average
point 5 and point 9 push it away so D
calling different sources and you need
to have this vehicle variance matrix it
has to be positive semi-definite and
there's some pieces for estimating which
I don't want to talk about but except
that it requires a little they're tricky
math because that matrix does need to be
positive semi-definite so for the math
geeks there's a little technical detail
to make it work out right the problem is
the empirical estimates aren't if you
just throw the correlations in there you
get all sorts of crap so you've got to
produce some clever of things to make
sure you actually get a sensible matrix
out the empirical estimate is not a good
one but that's way too technical so
let's do easily with with dumb
colleague of mine Don Moore went around
the Berkeley campus with a skill and a
camera took photos a bunch of people and
weighed them he's got a bunch of people
here's some real participants and know
how much they weigh so far so good
now we'll ask a bunch of other people
Berkeley students how much does each
person way now you might think I would
have thought a year ago two years ago
that the thing to do if you ask 20
Berkeley students the weight would be
that say average them right I got 20
estimates of their weight take the
average that's the good wisdoms the
crowd thing it's not bad but here are 20
different photographed people and
weights the red is the true weight of
the person and you see the histograms
and what you can see is that on average
the median rater of all these readers is
under estimating the weight of the heavy
people and overestimating the weight of
the light people you with me the average
or the median Eve in this case the
median is better the average but the
median estimate is shrunk toward the
mean even though I don't know the mean
with me
so something funky is happening it's not
the case that just taking the median
estimate is good we want to take the
heavy weights median and squish it up
and the loved ones that push them down
and we can use the covariance across
these different raters this is weird
they're all seeing the same information
it's a photo what do I think's happy I
don't know but I think they're looking
at the face looking at the weight look
at the male or female looking at
different features different people pay
attention to different things and based
on that there's some correlation
structure over the ratings the estimates
of the weight
and if we do a better job well here is
the average as I think number
forecasters going from 10 to 70 the
average gets the error we mean squared
error goes down the there's the median
there's the average and black is our
revealed aggregator Arts is it statistic
with less than 20 people you're actually
better off taking the average because we
can't get a good estimate the covariance
matrix as I get more than 20 people we
get noticeably lower error then
averaging the weights the same thing
happens with uglier math with
probabilities 92 link function they're
no longer real numbers and you get
something sort of fancier but basically
still has this covariance matrix in
there plus a few other crappy pieces
that I want to talk about but it's
basically the same sort of thing but
uglier is probability x' you need a
inverse cumulative distribution function
for the gaussian and what do you see
forecasters going from 10 to 50 root
mean squared error the average goes down
and get more people with low clouds the
median is much better the average of
probabilities is crappy because they're
not good a better thing is to average
log odds which are closer to Gaussian so
that's even better or probe it's similar
and we're doing a lot better yeah we try
to harmonic mean we did all these it
turns out that none of them are as good
as actually using this covariance base
if people made a bunch of forecasts even
if you don't know the outcome then using
this covariance matrix helps I need to
move toward the summary piece here ten
more minutes before I get thrown off I
want to give a little bit of perspective
of what I think here I think tournaments
have maybe three main big uses it's a
testing ground we can check what works
what's different about people how are
actually open-minded thinking or
intelligent people or biases work we can
compare prediction markets versus
surveys for this stuff at least if you
can't do any statistics
all you do is average you use a
prediction market if you can have a for
a day of a good statistician the app in
the prediction polls are better ask
people probabilities and then do a
weighted combination of those we have
saw some cool things in aggregating
finding diversity not based on black
versus white
men versus women but diversity based on
the sheer empirical do we tend to mostly
agree or do we disagree more and I
haven't talked about today but there's
an interesting debate going on in the
intelligence community mostly they
reward process did you go through and
measure the right sort of things you
consider the right checklist did you
follow the process versus were you
accurate and we can look to see which of
those lead to better outcomes and not
surprisingly it's better to ask for
outcomes interestingly if you want good
reports you can do a hybrid system where
say hey I'll give you partly a reward
based on foiling the process generally a
good report and probably based on
accuracy I think the sort of get the
best of both worlds by combining those
they're economic functions firms can do
better job of predicting which is good
and I think more interestingly spot and
cultivate people astoundingly to me
again this hour of training and I only
gave you five minutes in an hour
helped if people actually had to make
predictions every week for a year and
one thing we found measuring
open-mindedness or active open-minded
thinking was one of the measures that
correlated and we looked over time
number of years people spent with both
surveys and prediction markets people
went up on average in their open-minded
thinking as measured by our
questionnaire that getting feedback that
said hey you missed it dah oh you got it
if you have that happen say a hundred
times people start to spend a little
more time you know more flexible about
considering alternate hypotheses as to
what might happen tournament I mean
either prediction market or a prediction
poll so I try to have some general
notion of this a group of people
competing in some sense by making
predictions so I'm trying to group my
prediction market pigeon polls in a
single competition with measured
outcomes
and all over and over again so there
were a hundred questions a year really
involve people did all all hundred
people often did yes thirty many people
did it for three years so it's thirty
questions to 100 questions a year for
three years for a mobile person going
through making predictions every week
and then you got it you missed it
yeah and I think it's something that's
widely missing in politics and I don't
mean even just in this amazing set of
Republican convention discussions but
this notion of a pure accuracy not just
what should be done but what will happen
and I think this notion of pushing for
actual quantitative forecasts and
accountability is at least one tiny
piece of a way that might bring a little
more sensibility discourse what do you
think the chance of this happening by
this date is rather than just yes it
will be horrible or wonderful or
whatever and mean if we do this we could
actually get the political process to
have more learning and feedback that
would be wonderful I'm more sanguine
about it happening actually in corporate
America where people really do care and
measure these things
finally this project is finished for the
first phase as the second phase starting
up but there is now a company which I'm
not have no financial interest in and
there is a good judgement open an
ongoing public platform you can go and
play yourself make the forecasts take
the training it's there and if ever any
more questions I'll take a few here but
people who do spend longer thinking on
the questions do in fact are more
accurate so certainly the amount of
that's your question the amount of time
spent on tasks correlates very highly
with accuracy people are warned gays to
work harder do better absolutely
this is long as I can tell it's pretty
monotonic I mean again there's a fair
amount of noise but in general the more
time people spend at it the better they
did yeah what about external factors
that you you know have nothing obvious
to do with the predictions humans work
on prediction markets where they waited
by risk tolerance there are other
external factors you know happy people
versus sad people are just crazy things
that you could think of where might
poorly in like we didn't we try to bunch
of those including you know political
orientation and lots of things that
might have made differences and although
what I reported all the ones we found
lots of other things didn't appear to
matter or at least were too small to
measure but if it's too small to measure
here it's gonna be a long time before
someone does another really in the
forecast measured like that
so could matter but I couldn't find him
subject selection yeah pulling agencies
into but I'm wondering if your
correlation adjustment might actually be
fun to go back so for example I was a
fiction market at Google where they had
predictions of product launch successes
what you find is that more senior people
did better than junior ones people who
were to close the project were too
optimistic as you got a bit farther away
you got better and so I do think that if
you have that sort of information you
should be able to actually feed it in
and do the relating and again the
problem of the prediction market it's a
black box you can't go in and tanker we
try it a bit but it's really hard to go
in and and tweak the prediction market
whereas if I ask you probability I can
use all sorts of facts about you is it
your project is it not your project to
do appropriate re-weighting as I think
I've become a huge fan of prediction
polls ask people and
learn something about them and then use
that to the aggregation rather than to
let the market do itself these are not
like financial markets where there's in
theory always more money to flow in
there's a limited number of people who
are going to predict your product or
your outcome so there are lots of
prediction markets running the Iowa
markets make predictions they have been
historically fairly accurate you can
pair across different ones you can see
the variance across times it'll
arbitrage possibility they don't do
quite quite as well as the very clever
forecasters that take the picture
markets as one of their inputs their
algorithms but they do fairly well
actually for the for the US markets
where there's fairly good information
the question becomes more problematic is
as you go to more and more obscure
countries and pieces there how do you
for internet companies we have smaller
sets of people how do you do that and
again the prediction market can very
thin we only have five or ten people
whereas friction polls you can always
ask to five or 10 people their
probability and then aggregate them in a
sensible fashion so again I think the
prediction polling is much more flexible
on this small side which I see is more
common across from intelligence agencies
to company thing to watch is do you want
to make sure there's no vested interest
in the parties in question in gaming the
system so I found with a lot of these if
somebody wants to make their candidate
look good then they push the pieces
there so it's gotta be a little bit
careful that it's not structured in a
way where people have some incentive to
lie to you which is often the case so
that's my one big concern these we are
going to try hope to do some of these
with marketing forecasting to get a
bunch of people I think we should be
able do a better job than purchasing
agents at deciding what to buy for the
next fashion season but we'll see
yes but in many cases the outcome what
people are rewarded for is not
prediction accuracy yes in general
people are not rewarded for prediction
accuracy that is in fact a huge problem
persons do say market prediction is not
the person who's best it's the one who
makes the most money for making market
predictions which is a different
property well I think particularly
within companies different pundits have
the idea of making a prediction that
will actually get them on television
which encourages ridiculous things and
people at many companies I remember I
won't name the company but a major chip
manufacturer not located here if you
were made a high sales forecast you
could reserve more time on the
manufacturing plant they've made a low
forecast you couldn't reserve time and
there was no cost for overestimating
guess what all the salespeople did that
contract will be here next month no
problem
sign me up on the machine because if I
can't make that custom ship next month I
can't get my commission this is a huge
problem with people not being assented
or being disincentive but again that
partly comes from not keeping score
these salespeople were never penalized
in any fashion for being systematically
optimistic on their forecasts so yes you
need to may have a reward structure that
makes this actually matter and that
means a cultural change yep patrollers
you can ask you this have to be
correlated process to so that isn't they
devised a up in three parts of the third
part so you can't cheat pensively not
even a smart gal gadot can she yes she
yeah yeah these are able to do that to
these forecasts except for the pictures
of the thinner and heavier people were
fictions about the future about unknown
events there was no way to cheat because
nobody actually knew the future and so I
do think that having this make the
forecast write it down have it something
have a systematic go back and look at it
that's
really basic yeah if you're the right
organization here's the thing I don't
have a security clearance but I'm told
by leaked information published in The
Washington Post that we are more
accurate on the exact same questions
that the internal picture market of the
security agencies did so that people
having confidential information we're
less accurate an average than our people
you can action right so all these are
subject something sir if you can
actually affect it if you if you have
the the your finger on the trigger you
could literally then you can change
things
absolutely and that's another question
of incentive compatibility our
forecasters then right none of our right
none of our forecasters are in a
position to actually pull triggers I
hope if I was doing studies a bunch of
experts and I give them a bunch of
questions would I be able to take the
correlations on those questions and then
we adjust the same question please no
you can take okay what you're doing is
taking their predictions not looking the
outcome at all you're taking their
predictions finding the covariance the
correlation structure of the predictions
that's the only thing that that's my
signal that's my covariance that was
that those blocks take that basically
and invert it and then rescale it on the
diagonal with a little piece there and
then use that to combine their
predictions on the exact same data set
but now you're looking at at the
prediction so so yeah it's it sounds
almost circular it does require people
EVF make very strong assumptions only
take one prediction which we're working
on but it works best if you have a bunch
of predictions by the same people now
many of these are only partially
overlapping because of our hundred
questions a lot of people did different
thirty but there's enough overlap to
estimate that matrix and and then
basically invert it to do the weighting
the publication to look for or this
method or to cite it would it be article
by you or is it so we have a bunch of
these in this political science I guess
there's two sets of them there's one
fact this through the Phil tetlock has a
book if you want the qualitative one
there's a book which do a quartet lock
has the big picture political science
one bar Millers and a bunch of us
ability have a psych psych psych science
on the psychology and via and I have a
bunch of statistics ones the simplest
thing to do is to email me I'm Unger you
nga are at Penn and I with whatever
question I'll point you to which of the
the literature's are very different in
style the book is quite popular Phil's
book really readable Vilas stuff is
stuff that you would like because it's
real mathematics in it so these are in
Jassa and you know real statistics
journals so we're all over the map stuff
on these things and he gives a great
talk but there's no pretty good yeah you
can come in and out but those more
interesting which which prediction
markets would you recommend to watch for
this this election round there is
actually a site ours tracker that goes
most efficient markets are outside the
US the US government really strongly
regulates who can run a picture markets
viewed as gambling so most pressure
markets are outside there is a site odds
tracker that has five or seven different
prediction markets you can look and see
the agreement between them but they're
all pretty efficient in the sense they
tend to agree with each other no it's
less regulated so it's easier to start
one you you cannot drop and start a
prediction market without no it just
makes it harder to lose the the number
of picture markets
yes and the interesting thing is is that
although in theory could arbitrage is
just not enough money most of them have
very tight caps on how much money you
can put in especially within the US ones
and so there's arbitrage opportunity but
it's not very big and it's not a good
way to make a living if you yeah great
thank you all hang out the questions
here wonderful
you